I knew he was a special person and it
had nothing to do with his education it
had nothing to do with his potential and
I say this to young women don't and
check off there are a lot of women who
had the boxes did he go to the right
school what does it income you know it
was none of that it was how he felt
about his mother the love that he felt
for his mother his relationship to women
his work ethic we work together in a
firm he did his work and he was good and
he was smart and I like that and he was
low-key and he wasn't impressed with
himself and he was funny and we joked a
lot and he loved his little sister those
were the things and he was a community
organizer I really respected that here
we are in a big law firm right and
everybody was pushing to make money he
was one of the smartest students at
Harvard Law School one of the smartest
associates in our firm he had the chance
to clerk for the Supreme Court and I
thought what you're definitely gonna do
that right only a few people even have
the chance to do that it was really I
think I can do more work working with
folks in churches oh that's different
and he meant it it wasn't a line he
wasn't trying to impress me
it was those kind of values that made me
think you don't meet people like that
often and will you couple that with
talent and she's cute and I always
thought he would be useful but I I had
no idea he would be president I didn't
think he was gonna be president until
the night we were standing on the stage
and he actually won oh my God look yeah
you won
you